who EJ my number one rockin Oscar she
back yeah shut up Mouse everybody's a
shot on us continent number Morocco
North Korea Kim Jong
sup you guys we are new heights we'll be
working today with the famous Kim Jong
illa um we're really excited we're not
sure what he's gonna bring to the table
but I guess we'll see can't go you guys
in there but I'll try something new you
know that one only thing I prayed up is
a Kim Jong hear Kim Jong near Kim Jong
ear and I died the overturn that's like
the text look isn't it dead
yes she bought my ghost will never die I
think you know is gonna come in today
and not exactly sure what okay yeah I
miss raela just want to introduce myself
and see how do I feel about it he
freaking slap me yeah I don't think
mister illa likes Kris too much or they
take me on is gonna something missing on
me during the bridge throw those ranges
yeah hey guys are you indeed a South
Korean boy yeah boy what was this one
here okay yeah it was weird
I he wouldn't stop harassing him the
whole day I'm thinking maybe during the
chorus maybe even the bridge I'm sure
that's gonna clash yeah that's what I
only consider by after harmony not not
not not my only F that's not
yeah South Korea knock-knock fine who's
there yeah I'm good yeah I usually don't
get offended easily but man this guy's
been pushing it
must be smart yes like my hat he's a
little culturally insensitive and no
it's that it did diaper you don't have
the pendency power you don't have a pen
see Tom
you think I'm Middle Eastern no not this
pissy you know Sheba I don't know how
I'm supposed to play music when I'm this
freaked out it's really impossible
she's a good one okay yeah okay
oh she's a key okay yeah you're locked
on the back yeah seriously
oh my gosh that's crazy
he's only aggressive towards the white
people in the South Korean people
yeah Ito like I'm getting secured no no
come on gene oh oh
what about it there you go oh I have no
idea why he just said
okay so um I'm going to teach you or
song take me on mm-hmm
so it was like this um I've been going
through this evidence of you girl
yeah I never used all love a good time
yeah yeah Jake that is this kid it's
good no no Charlie because I've been
going through this no I always you said
love always my time that's the perp yeah
yeah when I said no that's not what I
did
yeah she might like Mike is a perfect no
I'm Sam I say is not perfect are you
okay yeah you died out yet oh I'm not
saying something
I'm not saying yeah I good perfect good
man
oh stop the mob today was a blessing you
know I don't think things could have
gone any better
is he watching please help us oh you
talk a lot of [ __ ] oh okay yeah
okay
I never he saw always ECU time never
part itself I never you mind
do you die Donna Donna dudes what nice
she might not get done it yeah yeah I
wrote about it never is some oral or the
water to turn yes you could look up your
mama she bhai no yo
hey it's ji these two paths Wow okay
yeah